THE MEANTIME HERE'S SEAN
HANNITY.
>> Sean: TUCKER WELCOME BACK
GOOD TO HAVE YOU WELCOME TO
HANNITY.
WHILE PRESIDENT BIDEN LOUNGES ON
THE BEACH UNTIL SOUTH CAROLINA,
WE'RE TRACKING MULTIPLE BREAKING
STORIES INCLUDING NEW
DEVELOPMENT ON THE SHOOTING
DEVELOP CAUSED BY ALEC BALDWIN
MORE HYPOCRISY ON CLIMATE CHANGE
THIS TIME WITH HYPOCRITE
LEONARDO DICAPRIO.
WAIT UNTIL YOU HEAR WHAT HE DID.
AND A SHOCKING REPORTED FROM
MINNESOTA WHERE ONE TEACHER'S
UNION WOULD DECIDE TO LAY PEOPLE
OFF BASED ON THEIR RACE
REGARDLESS OF THEIR SENIORITY.
WE'LL TELL YOU THAT STORY.
AND LATER WE'LL SHOW HOW ONE
BRAVE GOOD SAMARITAN TOOK
MATTERS INTO HIS OWN HANDS BY
CHASING DOWN A VIOLENT ROBBERY
SUSPECT.
BUT FIRST TONIGHT, TENSIONS
REMAIN VERY HIGH ONLY ONE WEEK
AFTER THE FBI'S RAID ON THE 45TH
PRESIDENT'S HOME, MAR-A-LAGO.
NOW, THIS UNPRECEDENTED SEARCH
AND SEIZURE HAS FURTHER ERODED
SADLY MANY AMERICANS TRUST IN
THE FBI AND THE DOJ AND IS NOW
CAUSING THE OUTRAGE ALL ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, THE FBI HAS
EARNED THEIR SHATTERED
REPUTATION AND TONIGHT WE'RE
GOING TO BREAK DOWN VERY
SPECIFICALLY WHY CONSERVATIVES,
AND TRUMP SUPPORTERS AND MANY
REPUBLICANS NO LONGER TRUST WHAT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN AND SHOULD BE
AND CAN BE AND ONCE WAS THE
PREMIER LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD.
LET ME BE CLEAR.
AND THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT.
CRITICIZING AND QUESTIONING THE
ATROCIOUS BEHAVIOR OF THE UPPER
ECHELON OF THE FBI IS NOT IN ANY
WAY, SHAPE, MANNER OR FORM, A
CALL TO VIOLENCE.
JUST TODAY, FOX NEWS IS LEARNING
THAT FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP
DIRECTED HIS TEAM TO REACH OUT
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE,
THE MESSAGE, DONALD TRUMP WILL
DO WHATEVER HE CAN TO HELP OUR
COUNTRY BECAUSE, QUOTE, THE
TEMPERATURE HAS TO BE BROUGHT
DOWN.
NOW, PRESIDENT TRUMP IS RIGHT.
ON THIS PROGRAM WE TOTALLY
CONDEMN ALL THREATS AGAINST THE
FBI AND EVERY OTHER MEMBER OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
YOU WATCH THIS SHOW, WE ARE
CONSISTENT.
NO DOUBT THERE ARE COPS THAT ARE
BAD APPLES.
WE SAW THAT IN THE GEORGE FLOYD
CASE.
THEY COMMIT CRIMES, ABUSE THEIR
POWER AND TARGET THEIR POLITICAL
ENEMIES.
THOSE PEOPLE MUST ALL BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE IN A COURT OF LAW,
AND THAT WOULD ALSO APPLY TO BAD
APPLES IN THE FBI.
NOW, SADLY, THAT ALMOST NEVER
HAPPENS.
IF DONALD TRUMP OR A TRUMP
SUPPORTER IS THE TARGET OF THE
ABUSE.
FOR EXAMPLE, TAKE A LOOK AT
FORMER FBI OFFICIAL PETER
STRZOK, THINK DEEPLY GO BACK TO
AUGUST 8, 2016, HIS GIRLFRIEND
TOP FBI LAWYER LISA PAGE
ABSOLUTELY TERRIFIED AT THE
PROSPECT OF A TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
SHE TEXT PETER STRZOK HER
COLLEAGUE, TRUMP'S NEVER GOING
TO BECOME PRESIDENT, RIGHT?
RIGHT?
HE RESPONDS HE'S NOT, WE'LL STOP
IT.
HE SAID ALL OF THAT AS A TOP FBI
OFFICIAL, ONE THAT WORKED
DIRECTLY FOR THE TOP LEADERSHIP
IN THE FBI.
THEN A WEEK LATER, STRZOK
TESTED, QUOTE, I WANT TO BELIEVE
THAT THE PATH YOU THROUGH OUT
FOR CONSIDERATION IN ANDY,
PRESUMABLY ANDREW McCABE'S
OFFICE, THAT THERE'S NO WAY HE
GETS ELECTED.
BUT I'M AFRAID WE CAN'T TAKE
THAT RISK.
IT'S LIKE AN INSURANCE POLICY IN
THE UNLIKELY EVENT YOU DIE
BEFORE 40.
SO A TOP FBI AGENT, WITH AN
INSURANCE POLICY, WILL STOP IT
TO THWART THE WILL OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND ENSURE THAT
ONE CANDIDATE CAN NEVER WIN A
FREE AND FAIR ELECTION IN
AMERICA.
BY THE WAY, WHERE'S THAT
JANUARY 6TH COMMITTEE LOOKING
INTO THIS ISSUE?
NOW, OF COURSE THE INSURANCE
POLICY WAS NONE OTHER THAN THE
RUSSIA CONCLUSION HOAX, PETER
STRZOK BECAME THE LEAD
INVESTIGATOR INTO THE BOGUS
CONSPIRACY THEORY.
HIS BIAS WAS CAREER AND OBVIOUS
AND POLITICAL AND STRZOK NEVER
EVER FACED LEGAL CONSEQUENCES.
IT'S WHY I OFTEN SAY WE DON'T
HAVE EQUAL JUSTICE OR EQUAL
APPLICATION OF OUR LAWS IN
AMERICA ANY LONGER.
THAT IS A SAD THING TO SAY, BUT
SADLY IT'S TRUE.
STRZOK ENDS UP WITH A BOOK DEAL,
HIS ANTI TRUMP FBI GIRLFRIEND
GOT HIRED BY MSDNC.
STRZOK HIS SEM HAS RECEIVED
NUMEROUS INVITATIONS TO APPEAR
ALL OVER CABLE NEWS INCLUDING
THIS MORNING, ON WITH LIBERAL
MORNING JOE, OUR OLD FRIEND.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT'S NOT THAT THE FBI IS
TARGETING ANY ONE SIDE OR THE
OTHER.
WHAT YOU SEE IS THE FBI GOING
OUT ON A DAY IN DAY OUT BASIS
OBJECTIVELY INVESTING
ALLEGATIONS OF LAW.
>> Sean: A GUY THAT SAID WE'LL
STOP IT, WE'LL STOP IT, THE FBI
WILL STOP IT AND IF YOUR PLAN
DOESN'T WORK WE HAVE AN
INSURANCE POLICY, NO WAY HE'S
GOING TO WIN.
THE LACK OF SELF AWARENESS
THERE, SHOULD SEEM SHOCKING TO
EVERYBODY BUT KEEP IN MIND
NEITHER STRZOK OR HIS SUPERIORS
AT THE FBI HAVE EVER BEEN HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
FOR EXAMPLE HIS BOSS McCABE WAS
VERY OPEN ABOUT HIS HATE FOR
TRUMP.
AND YATES, SALLY YATES, ROD
ROSENSTEIN ALL SIGNED OFF ON
EITHER THE FISA WARRANT OR THE
THREE SUBSEQUENT RENEWAL
WARRANTS.
IN DOING SO, ALL OF THEM LIED ON
AN APPLICATION THAT AT THE TOP
OF THE APPLICATION SAYS
VERIFIED, THAT THEY VERIFIED THE
INFORMATION.
WE NOW KNOW NONE OF IT WAS TRUE,
ALL OF THE INFORMATION THAT THEY
USED WAS UNVERIFIABLE BECAUSE
IT'S ALL BEEN DEBUNKED.
THEY COMMITTED A FRAUD AGAINST A
COURT OF LAW, NO EQUAL JUSTICE
OR APPLICATION OF OUR LAWS,
NOBODY WAS HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
THE EVIDENCE THEY USED WAS
NEITHER TRUE NOWHERE WAS IT
VERIFIED OR VERIFIABLE.
THE BULK OF THE SUPPORTING
MATERIAL IN EACH OF THOSE FISA
APPLICATIONS WAS THAT WOMAN,
HILLARY ROD AM CLINTON'S DIRTY
RUSSIAN MISINFORMATION DOSSIER
THAT SHE PAID FOR.
THEY WERE WARNED THE DOSSIER WAS
FILLED WITH SALACIOUS CAMPAIGN
OP RESEARCH INCLUDING RUSSIAN
MISINFORMATION AND IT WAS NOT TO
BE TRUSTED WARNED BY EVEN BRUCE
ORR IN 2016 SAYING DON'T USE IT
AND YET THEY USED IT ANYWAY AND
SWORE IN A COURT OF LAW THAT IT
WAS VERIFIED BECAUSE ASTHMA CAB
ONCE ADMITTED, THEY DIDN'T HAVE
THAT DOSSIER, THEY WEREN'T GOING
TO GET THE FISA APPLICATION
APPROVED AND THEY WERE DESPERATE
TO SPY ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AT
THAT PARTICULAR TIME.
AND THE TRUMP TRANSITION TEAM,
AND LATER THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE.
NO ONE WAS EVER CHARGED WITH
LYING TO THE FISA COURT, EVEN
AFTER THEY ALL ADMITTED, OH, YOU
KNOW, WELL, I GUESS IF I HAD TO
DO IT ALL OVER AGAIN, I WOULDN'T
DO IT.
AND IF I KNEW NOW WHAT I SHOULD
HAVE KNOWN THEN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IF YOU KNEW THEN WHAT YOU
KNOW NOW, WOULD YOU HAVE SIGNED
THE WARRANT APPLICATION IN JUNE
OF 2017 AGAINST CARTER PAGE?
>> NO, SIR.
>> IF YOU KNEW THEN WHAT YOU
KNOW NOW, WOULD YOU HAVE SIGNED
A WARRANT APPLICATION?
>> NO, I WOULD NOT.
>> I BELIEVE YOU DIDN'T KNOW
THAT WHAT YOU SIGNED WAS WRONG.
THE QUESTION IS, IF YOU HAD
KNOWN YOU WOULDN'T HAVE SIGNED
IT.
IS THAT CORRECT?
>> NO, IF I HAD KNOWN THAT IT
CONTAINED INCORRECT INFORMATION,
I CERTAINLY WOULDN'T HAVE SIGNED
IT.
>> KNOWING THEN WHAT YOU KNOW
NOW ABOUT ALL THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE COME TO FIND, WOULD YOU
HAVE STILL SIGNED THE WARRANT
APPLICATION AGAINST CARTER PAGE
IN OCTOBER, JANUARY, AND APRIL.
>> NO, I WOULD WANT A MUCH MORE
COMPLETE UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
HE ON-
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Sean: SO THEY'RE ALL
ADMITTING THAT THEY SIGNED A
DOCUMENT THAT HAS VERIFIED, THE
WORD VERIFIED AT THE TOP WAS NOT
VERIFIABLE.
NOT ONE PERSON HELD ACCOUNTABLE
FOR WHAT IS CORRUPTION AND AN
EGREGIOUS ABUSE OF POWER,
ESPECIALLY NOT THE PATRON SAINT
OF THE FBI, JIM COMEY HIMSELF,
AFTER GETTING FIRED BY THE
FORMER PRESIDENT, COMEY OF
COURSE LEAKED PRIVILEGED
MATERIAL TO THE NEW YORK TIMES
THROUGH A FRIEND IN ORDER TO
SMEAR DONALD TRUMP.
OF COURSE, COMEY'S HOME WAS
NEVER RAIDED BY THE FBI.
BY THE WAY, NEITHER WAS HILLARY
CLINTON'S HOUSE IN CHAPPAQUA AND
SHE GROSSLY MISHANDLED
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION AND THEN
ATTEMPTED TO COVER HER TRACKS.
SHE DELETED 33,000 E-MAILS.
NOBODY HAD EVER HEARD OF BLEACH
BIT BEFORE THAT.
WE ALL KNOW WHAT IT IS NOW.
COMEY GAVE HER A FREE PASS.
THEN, EVEN THOUGH HE FOUND
EVIDENCE OF SERIOUS CRIMES,
INCLUDING THE KNACK HER SERVERS
WERE HACKED BY FOREIGN ENTITIES
THAT PUT OUR COUNTRY AT RISK,
NO, WE'RE NOT GOING TO CHARGE
HILLARY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SECRETARY CLUB TON'S USE OF A
PERSONAL E-MAIL DOMAIN WAS BOTH
KNOWN BY A LARGE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE AND READILY APPARENT.
SHE ALSO USED HER PERSONAL
E-MAIL EXTENSIVELY WHILE OUTSIDE
THE UNITED STATES INCLUDING
SENDING AND RECEIVING
WORK-RELATED E-MAILS IN THE
TERRITORY OF SOPHISTICATED
ADVERSARIES.
GIVEN THAT COMBINATION OF
FACTORS, WE ASSESS IT IS
POSSIBLE THAT HOSTILE ACC TOURS
GAINED ACCESS TO SECRETARY
CLINTON'S PERSONAL E-MAIL
ACCOUNT.
>> Sean: HOSTILE REGIMES HAD
ACCESS TO TOM SECRET CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
SHE ALLOWED THAT TO HAPPEN AND
SHE WAS NOT HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
SO LET'S BE VERY CLEAR HERE.
IF YOU'RE HILLARY CLINTON AND
PUT YOUR COUNTRY AT RISK, YOU'RE
GOING TO GET A FREE PASS.
IF YOU'RE JIM COMEY, YOU LEAK
CONFIDENTIAL GOVERNMENT MATERIAL
TO A FRIEND, TO THE MEDIA MOB,
YOU GET A FREE PASS.
IF YOU'RE A HIGH RANKING TRUMP
HATING BUREAUCRAT WHO LIES TO A
FISA COURT, YOU'LL ALSO GET A
FREE PASS.
IF YOU'RE A TOP FBI INVESTIGATOR
WHO VOWS TO USE HIS POWER TO
STOP A FREE AND FAIR ELECTION,
WE'LL STOP IT, WE'VE GOT AN
INSURANCE POLICY, YOU WILL A GET
A PASS ALSO.
IF YOU'RE HUNTER BIDEN, YOU CAN
SELL ACCESS TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, TO CHINA, TO RUSSIA,
TO UKRAINE, AND EVEN IMPLICATE
YOUR OWN FATHER, THE BIG GUY,
OVER AND OVER AGAIN, AND YOU'RE
GOING TO GET A PASS.
NO EARLY MORNING RAID ON HUNTER
BIDEN OR JOE BIDEN.
THAT WILL PROBABLY NEVER HAPPEN
DESPITE THE PRIMA FACIE CASE
AGAINST HIM.
AND IF YOU'RE JOE BIDEN, YOU CAN
LEVERAGE ONE BILLION TAXPAYER
DOLLARS TO GET A UKRAINIAN
PROSECUTOR FIRED INVESTING YOUR
CRACK ADDICTED SON WHO WAS
MAKING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
HE HAD NO EXPERIENCE WITH
UKRAINE OIL, ENERGY, GAS,
WHATSOEVER.
NOTHING'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
ON THE OTHER HAND, IF YOU ARE A
CONSERVATIVE, WATCH OUT.
IF YOU'RE ROGER STONE, YOU
COMMIT A PROCESS FINE, YOU LIED
TO CONGRESS, YOU'RE GOING TO GET
A MASSIVE PREDAWN RAID, GUNS
DRAWN FROG MEN IN THE WATER
COMPLETE WITH FAKE NEWS CNN
CAMERAS TIPPED OFF TO BE THERE
AT 5:45 IN THE MORNING AND FILM
IT ALL.
IF YOU'RE PAUL MANAFORT AND YOU
COMMIT A FAIR A VIOLATION OR TAX
VIOLATION, AGAIN HARDLY CRIMES
DANGEROUS TO SOCIETY, ANOTHER
MASSIVE PREDAWN RAID, GUNS
POINTED AT YOUR FACE, YOUR
WIFE'S FACE, FOLLOWED BY MONTHS
OF SOLITARY CONFINEMENT TO BREAK
YOU.
BY THE WAY, HIS NEW BOOK OUT,
YOU SHOULD READ IT, IT'S CALLED
POLITICAL PRISONER, IT'S OUT BY
THE WAY TOMORROW, PAUL MANAFORT
WILL BE ON THE SHOW TOMORROW,
YOU NEED TO READ THAT BOOK.
IF YOU'RE PETER NAVARRO YOU GET
CHARGED WITH A MISDEMEANOR AND
GET SHACKLED AT THE AIRPORT FOR
A MISDEMEANOR HANDCUFFED THROWN
IN JAIL THE SAME CELL JOHN
HINKLEY WAS THROWN IN THE GUY
WHO TRIED TO ASSASSINATE RONALD
REAGAN.
NOW THE 45TH PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES HAS BEEN TARGETED
BY AN EARLY I DIDN'T HAVE
MORNING RAID AND NOT ONLY DID
AGENTS SHOW UP IN FORCE, GUNS
DRAWN, TO THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
HOME BUT ALSO DEMANDED THAT THE
SECURITY CAMERAS BE TURNED OFF
AND THEY EVEN BLOCKED THE
PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEYS FROM
OBSERVING THE SEARCH.
NOW WHY WOULD THEY DO THAT?
HOW MANY YEARS HAVE WE FOUGHT
FOR BODYCAMS ON POLICE TO KEEP
EVERYBODY HONEST?
WHY WOULDN'T YOU WANT THE
SURVEILLANCE CAMERAS KEPT ON?
ANYTHING YOU'RE HIDING.
TONIGHT CONGRESS HAS A DUTY TO
HOLD THE FBI AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE, THOSE PEOPLE AT THE
TOP LEVELS ACCOUNTABLE.
INSTEAD, TOP DEMOCRATS IN THE
MAJORITY ARE ACTING LIKE
CHEERLEADERS.
JUST LISTEN TO THE CON GENITAL
LIAR HIMSELF, ADAM SHIFT.
>> IF THE TRUMP PEOPLE
REPRESENTED THEY PROVIDED ALL
THE CLASSIFIED AND NATIONAL
SECURITY INFORMATION AND DIDN'T,
THAT'S A SERIOUS PROBLEM AND I
CAN TELL YOU ANYONE IN THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY THAT HAD
DOCUMENTS LIKE THAT MARKED TOP
SECRET, FBI, IN THEIR RESIDENTS
AFTER AUTHORITIES WENT TO THEM,
YOU KNOW, THEY WOULD BE UNDER
SERIOUS INVESTIGATION.
>> Sean: YOU MEAN LIKE HILLARY?
THAT'S RIGHT, SHE'S A DEMOCRAT,
WHY TALK ABOUT HER.
WHEN IT COMES TO DONALD TRUMP OR
TRUMP ASSOCIATES, IT'S ALWAYS
GUILTY UNTIL PROVEN INNOCENT AND
THAT CONGENITAL LIAR BY THE WAY
DOESN'T CARE ABOUT EVIDENCE OR
TRUTH, HE JUST WANTS TO SMEAR,
SLANDER, BESMIRCH DONALD TRUMP
EVERY MOMENT OF EVERY DAY.
OF COURSE FOR YEARS THE MEDIA
MOB HAS ALWAYS BEEN HAPPY TO
GIVE THAT LIAR A PLATFORM TO
SPEW EVEN MORE LIES.
HERE'S A QUICK REMINDER.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS SOMEONE WHO
HAS SHOWN WHEN HE'S NOT HELD
ACCOUNTABLE HE GOES ON TO COMMIT
WORSE AND WORSE ABUSES OF POWER.
SO I AGREE WITH JUDGE IN
CALIFORNIA, I THINK THERE WAS
EVIDENCE THE FORMER PRESIDENT
ENGAGED IN MULTIPLE VIOLATIONS
OF THE LAW, AND THAT SHOULD BE
INVESTING.
>> WE HAVE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES ENGAGED IN A SHAKE
DOWN OF A FOREIGN PRESIDENT, A
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
EVEN AS HE IS WITHHOLDING VITAL
MILITARY SUPPORT TO AN ALLY,
ASKING A FAVOR OF THAT ALLY TO
INVESTIGATE HIS OPPONENT.
>> I'VE BEEN VERY CLEAR OVER THE
LAST YEAR, YEAR AND A HALF THAT
THERE IS AMPLE EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION IN PLAIN SIGHT.
>> I CAN CERTAINLY SAY WITH
CONFIDENCE THAT THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION BETWEEN THE CAMPAIGN
AND RUSSIA.
>> THERE IS ALREADY IN MY VIEW
AMPLE EVIDENCE IN THE PUBLIC
DOMAIN ON THE ISSUE OF
COLLUSION.
IF YOU'RE WILLING TO SEE IT.
>> Sean: ADAM SHIFT IS A
DISHONEST CORRUPT LIAR POLITICAL
HACK BUT SADLY MANY LEADERS IN
THE FBI ARE JUST MIRRORING THE
KIND OF DESTRUCTIVE UNETHICAL
BEHAVIOR AS HIM.
LET ME BE UNEQUIVOCAL IN MY
STATEMENT.
WE DON'T SUPPORT VIOLENCE AS
CONSERVATIVES.
WE BELIEVE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
LAW AND ORDER AND SECURITY.
AND WE BELIEVE ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT NEEDS TO BE
PROTECTED.
WE JUST WANT YOU TO STOP GIVING
US REASONS NOT TO TRUST YOU.
YOU'RE EARNING DISTRUST BY
ALLOWING ALL OF THESE PEOPLE
THAT ARE CORRUPT AND ABUSED
POWER TO GET AWAY WITH IT.
DIRECTOR WRAY CLEAN UP THIS
MESS.
STOP TREATING CONSERVATIVES ONE
WAY DEMOCRATS ANOTHER WAY,
THAT'S A GREAT FIRST STEP THEN
GET RID OF THE BAD APPLES AT THE
TOP OF YOUR ORGANIZATION.
PUNISH THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
CORRUPT.
PUNISH THE PEOPLE THAT ABUSE
THEIR POWER, BECAUSE IT'S
TARNISHING THE REPUTATION OF THE
95% OF GOOD AGENTS THAT SERVE
THIS COUNTRY WITH HONOR AND
DISTINCTION AND IT'S UNFORTUNATE
THAT MOST OF US WHO ARE THE MOST
INCLINED TO REVERE LAW
ENFORC